JENNY BROWN: Today we're talking
about code secrets, health care
consent, no-code hackathons,
and new podcasts.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Secret Manager is a
Google Cloud service
that provides a secure
and convenient method
for storing API keys,
passwords, certificates,
and other sensitive data.
Secret Manager provides a
central place and single source
of truth to manage,
access, and audit secrets
across Google Cloud.
The integration with
Cloud Code brings
those powerful capabilities
to your preferred IDE.
Check out the post or
video to learn more
about how to make your
code as secure as possible.
The Health Care
Consent Management API
is now generally available,
giving customers the ability
to greatly scale the
management of patient consent
to meet increasing
need, particularly
amidst the emerging
task of managing health
data for new care and
research scenarios.
To learn more, check
out the full post.
Hackathons are a great way to
mix things up and supercharge
your brainstorming,
and with no-code tools,
non-technical
employees can transform
into citizen developers who
are empowered to use technology
to build creative solutions.
AppSheet, Google Cloud's
no-code application development
platform, is a game changer,
so check out the blog
to learn more.
Google Cloud Reader
is an audio companion
to many of the posts
on our tech blog.
With new episodes on
Tuesdays and Thursdays,
you'll be able to hear about
a range of topics from cloud
storage to machine learning.
No matter why you
prefer an audio format,
we've got you covered.
Check it out wherever
you listen to podcasts.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.